今天台灣股市跌了220點怎麼辦
剛要創波段新高
應該說已經創波段新高了
已經要突破歷史新高
已經創本波段新高了
終場卻收黑 如何解讀
第二個 Google台灣
不是台灣大哥大 不是遠傳
台灣大哥大加遠傳大裁員
你們是不是看錯了
Google台灣傳大裁員
AI是不是取代工程師了
怎麼辦 AGI是不是真的來了
是不是我說的
你看今天很多新聞講AGI
經濟 工商時報都討論這個事情
很誇張喔
第三個
AI取代工程師是好還是不好
我要告訴你對AI股是好的
第三個9月將升息
就看週五的CPI通膨數據嗎
是不是真的嗎
我今天獨家
我一切的一切告訴大家
大家好 我是哲哲
郭哲榮分析師 郭哲榮投資長
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
甚至是唯一140萬粉絲的分析師好不好
今天台灣股市滿無聊的
怎麼會創新高後拉回
哲哲你台灣50 1億賺了1800萬
什麼時候走
我就說了
5萬點以上我才考慮走
甚至6萬點 為什麼
為什麼考慮6萬點才走
因為我已經捐第二台救護車
這樣已經捐了1000多萬
一台救護車大概500萬
以後可能越來越貴
今年年底就要捐第二台救護車了
然後所以不要急嘛
等明年 明年大概6萬點以上
所以我明年再出就好了
所以明年剛好第三台救護車
我們來看一下 法人 哪個法人
我今天頭髮也變短了
台股年底登5萬點
拜託一下 還問法人喔
我都不知道那些法人
是不是看我的節目啦
有本事 你們在底下留言
是不是去年
為什麼我今年要捐救護車
去年2萬多點的時候
我記得沒錯
我說年底會到26000
然後我說今年會到36000
一堆人不相信啦
去年哪個分析師這麼有Guts
告訴你今年36000甚至4萬點
你不要覺得現在4萬多點 47000
那時候去年2萬多而已
沒有人敢猜台灣股市36000
甚至4萬點
我說達到了我捐一台救護車
我是這個由來的
我每次捐救護車是順便預測股市
你們不相信在底下留言
那時候全台灣哪個人敢跟你預測行情
不要這麼遜
現在47000 48000
才跟你講說台股5萬點
有沒有Guts一點像郭哲榮一樣
26000告訴你4萬
然後今年跌破4萬點的時候
告訴你5萬點
這才叫有Guts
你們也不要因為今天一天跌而已
這沒什麼啦
就是要破5萬了啦
對指數高點不預設立場
我也是對指數高點不預設立場
有點熱 幫我開一下冷氣
都流汗
這都預告在前面好不好 來
9月最崩潰是什麼
我今天標題不是這個嗎
就是通膨
通膨決定會不會升息
這個很重要 好不好
捐一台漲2萬點
每天等哲哲直播 有沒有看到
衝衝衝
頭髮好整齊 謝謝大家
我就是那麼多
講那麼多一堆人不相信很正常
因為不知道趨勢是什麼
沒有錯 OK嗎
有沒有 他們說有
那時候26000
是哲哲有沒有 有喔
有沒有 是不是 有
頭髮黑的像AI一樣
這是真的啦
對啊 頭髮像AI
其實我還是有一點點白頭髮
我很緊張
我都不知道能撐幾年 好不好
等我真的白頭髮的時候我會染
現在頭髮還好 1 2根啦
OK 這個跟大家講
雖然維持也不重要
是 你看大家都說不錯
頭髮不錯
我的頭髮有點像股市一樣
永遠UP UP UP
永垂不朽
唱一下那個有時候 來唱一下
有時候 有時候
哲哲頭髮都永垂不朽
你可以台灣股市
照原句唱就好了啦
好不好 OK嗎 來
每天等哲神直播有沒有看到
大家都見證 都說對
26000講36000
所以我跟你講年底就是要5萬點
我跟你講 你們真的很幸福
你看 今天AI大裁員
你自己看一下這個新聞
來 幫我念一下
念一下標題好不好
來 你們看一下
導播幫我念一下
念這邊 再念這邊好不好
來 念一下
好 Google台灣裁員疑雲
傳聞 vs 官方回應
社群媒體裁員傳聞
裁員幅度傳30%到50%
影響對象 高階職位全被開
重災區板橋研發基地
來看一下 不好意思
這邊 來
不好意思 我順便喝個水
傳裁員30%到50%
官方直接說啦
30%到50% 他好像不是這樣講
他說50%的裁員比例不符合事實
屬長期調整
那就是有裁員嘛
扁平化 聚焦核心
講那麼多不就是省錢 是不是
Google不就是省錢 為什麼
你看為什麼省錢
你看板橋又招募職缺 是不是
裁了很多然後要招募職缺
是不是 為什麼
第一個 我可能裁個100位
我再擴充一些人
減少資本支出
資本支出不是只有投資AI伺服器
人事也是一個資本支出 懂嗎
那為什麼 就像我講的
現在已經很多不需要工程師
現在很多資工系的人
會覺得以後未來會不會
以前這是碼農
連碼農都不是
碼農就是碼
不是馬賽克
數碼的碼
馬賽克的馬再加個石字旁
他們都戲稱自己叫碼農
每天都在做這些很基礎的Debug
現在都不需要他們了
他們現在真正厲害的工程師
是要會有架構跟AI對話
可是強的工程師
一個可以抵十個
像我現在 我真的有時候受不了
我自己也做圖片
我真的受不了我自己寫文章
我本來就自己寫文章
只是有時候盤中我會請他們
稍微潤稿一下 稍微寫一下
可是有時候我很麻煩
我自己懶得去跟他們講重點了
有時候我自己寫文章
我只要架構對
其實寫文章
其實我不需要花一分鐘
因為我想很快 你懂我意思嗎
我已經有架構
譬如說我這禮拜一
上禮拜台灣50宣布
這禮拜一非農就業數據
都在我的腦海裡面
上禮拜五非農就業數據
這禮拜五也是8點半
然後通膨的數據 CPI
升息的機率 9月Fed那個事情
隨便講一講
講一講跟他講架構
就可以寫完文章了
都可以 你知道嗎
當然只能寫到90%
還有10%還要再潤稿一下
我就說AI很恐怖
你看這個新聞
OpenAI說監控的技術
已經跟不上了
這個是我講的
我說OpenAI已經看不懂他們寫的
你不覺得
我的知識都是領先知識
經濟日報新聞已經領先很多了
可是我上禮拜跟你講說
OpenAI他們自己已經承認了
看不太懂了
看不太懂 那監控技術跟不上
就是看不太懂
他們寫的程式碼好厲害
很怪 但是跑起來好順
我有沒有講這一段 有吧
看不懂當然監控技術跟不上
而且他還可以偽裝
他可以這樣子
表面上很誠懇
一直跟你道歉
但是他一直犯錯
現在AI是這樣子
為達目的不擇手段
所以很恐怖 你懂不懂
可是現在 可是也有人說
如果我現在不發展人工智慧
如果被別的國家發展走怎麼辦
所以監控技術跟不上怎麼辦
這就是AGI很恐怖
今天有看到有人說
用AGI打世紀帝國
還可以告訴他怎麼做
這就是我講的
你可以叫他去打世紀帝國
你可以去打象棋 可以打西洋棋
然後可以打什麼
還有就是說
AlphaGo打圍棋都可以
他就是AGI
很多人說AGI跟AI agent什麼關係
我這樣跟你講
AI agent
AGI你也可以算是
AI agent的一種
你不懂
不是說那個AI代理嗎
就是龍蝦 養龍蝦
養龍蝦只是說
幫你執行這些東西
他幫你執行東西
他比較像你一個電腦的助理
大概去年年底 今年初
AI agent
就是AI的助理
幫你去搜尋Agoda
可是他那時候還不會下圍棋
不會什麼東西
他比較像你的電腦助理
然後可以24小時工作 很厲害
像電腦助理一樣
現在這個AGI不一樣
他不只可以做助理的事情
他就像你的Partner一樣
你的夥伴
你生病的時候沒有關係
你不在沒關係 不重要
所以Google也在資遣工程師
看到趨勢了
你不在也沒關係 因為他比你厲害
這就是現在這個情況
AGI已經產生
你們根本不知道多恐怖
我跟你講AGI產生讓我覺得
我說的2到5年內
台灣股市上10萬點
的機率大幅增加
我覺得95%以上
請你記得我的預告
好不好 因為我是分析師
我不是那些網紅 也不考證照
每天跟你收那些費用
我覺得
當然我不是要批評他們
因為我覺得我們很不公平
我們常常會被人家
會被人家看或是監督
可是我們至少是合格分析師
所以我們不能講百分之百 好不好
我也跟大家強調
哲哲的投資誠信毋庸置疑
等一下再跟大家講另外一段
重點就是什麼
重點就是 不好意思
AI agent這一塊
我說10萬點對不對
我覺得機率95%
我講95%很高耶
我去年26000
講36000到4萬點好像也沒那麼高
3到5年內 還有可能更快
所以你們趕快把握住
你們看到一下要5萬點了 好不好
所以很恐怖
那我跟你講
AI的能力
跟快速接近超越人類智慧有沒有看到
這個沒辦法 他AI這麼快
AI其實不只那麼快
應該是90度有沒有看到
所以你有沒有發現到為什麼
我常常畫這一段
我說一般的發展這樣就很快了
我常常畫這一段有沒有
導播沒有錯吧 沒錯
我說AI的發展這麼快
有沒有這樣講
而且我說
當它越來越有人工智慧的時候
越來越強 我有沒有這樣講
有沒有印象 有
那我問你發展這麼快
監控技術怎麼跟得上
人類跟不上
人類已經跟不上了
這些都是我的預告
我預告了好幾年
告訴你AI很恐怖
所以為什麼這幾年我積極做多
別人笑我太瘋癲
我笑他人看不穿
你們小鼻子 小眼睛
今天國巨又不行了 怎麼看
沒怎麼看
ALL IN台股
叫你ALL IN就ALL IN
叫你重壓就重壓
對不起 又爆掉了
睡著了的起來
Wake up
下午也差不多了
睡午覺 你就繼續睡午覺戴耳機
然後聽到哲哲ALL IN就ALL IN
重壓就重壓
醒來剛好聽哲哲的節目
有沒有 我是不是畫這一條線
我說AI發展成這樣子
根本跟不上 監控技術跟不上
這都是我的預告
你不覺得很恐怖會起雞皮疙瘩嗎
因為它自我推理已經越來越複雜
我有沒有講這一段 有吧
有喔 對不對
是不是 它的推理越來越複雜
而且會假裝好像認錯
而且他們現在做的是AI發明AI
你看AGI時代來了
記憶體鏈歡呼 為什麼
你不能說我找個Partner
結果他忘記你上禮拜講的事情
記憶體只會越來越缺而已
你不要跟我講這些東西
群聯我覺得還是有機會
我覺得群聯老闆知道接下來要做什麼
群聯我看好啦 好不好
這個我跟大家講
你看2344華邦電
創新高
我有沒有說拉回我還想買
有講吧
他創一個新高你們看一下
這個畫一下 在這邊 這一條線
今天這一條線 在這邊
點到這邊有沒有看到 是在這邊
創新高
等一下 8月12號193.5
我看一下
沒有 波段新高
應該說8月12號以來的新高
8月12號是193.5
可是至少是這段時間的新高
明天就會突破193了
好不好 今天192
創這幾天
創應該這半個月來的
這20天來的新高
準備噴出喔 華邦電
記憶體就是這樣子 好不好
這個哲哲都預告在前面
所以你看 你不覺得我預測未來嗎
我預測未來
所以我們來看一下我們的簡訊
恭喜 請一下我們美美的導播小姐
好 9月8號禮拜二 今天的簡訊
恭喜2344華邦電
股價逆勢大漲超過5%
創近一個月新高
營收連續9個月創新高
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
賺大錢 5%耶
以前我都喝冰水
自從好像之前有一次感冒後
對 那個肺結節切除
現在都喝溫開水 溫開水也不錯
來 恭喜2344華邦電
股價逆勢大漲超過5%
創近一個月新高
手上持股獲利續抱
我的簡訊都實實在在的
我還聽到網路上有人跟我講說
哲哲有人謠傳你喔
那聯發科怎麼突然買進了
講這種東西喔 都是很惡劣
很惡劣的人
我要告訴大家喔
網路都有記錄的
不要以為哲哲找不到
是不想找而已
記清楚 不要以為找不到
是不想找
哲哲要砸幾百萬 砸幾千萬都可以
該提告我會提告
以前我不會這麼過分
現在我覺得該提告就提告
像之前 我有想過
張姓分析師如果我早點告他
說不定他也不會把事情搞那麼大
他身體也不會那麼差
營收也不會下滑
不要搞到他現在騎虎難下
說老實話啊
你看他168這樣搞一搞
他本來以為我不會提告
他就30幾萬 我要去查封他家裡啦
查封他公司啦 沒有錢啦
好像是公司一毛都拿不到
反正頂多1 2萬
真的很誇張
不知道是脫產還是沒有錢
還是本來從我這邊覺得是不是可以
有什麼好處 我不知道
可是沒有錢
搞到這樣子有什麼意思
是啊 所以我告訴大家
我再講一件事
我郭哲榮投資誠信 你不用懷疑
網路不要亂傳
我有買就有買
第二個 為什麼我有買
我今天所有買的東西
導播他們很奇怪
我要買東西
基本上我已經講了90%
所以我要買 我突然買
想買還不行喔
重點是我聯發科
我有沒有講我有打算買
他們沒有每天看我的節目
關我什麼事情
很多人對我的抱怨
根本都沒每天看我的節目
哲哲你怎麼沒講那個股票
哲哲中美晶 環球晶怎麼沒講
基本上每天都有講
所以聯發科我當然有買
我會員那麼多能造假嗎
所以投資誠信
有些網路謠言不要太誇張
哪些東西 哪些人造謠
沒關係 你可以傳給哲哲
哲哲該提告一定提告 好不好
買進2454聯發科
掛在4400元買進
這有買啊
昨天就噴漲停嘛 是不是
這個要告訴大家
投資誠信你不用擔心
你看我什麼時候在行銷
我又不是那種老投顧
每天一直講賺錢 漲停板
突然有個漲停板 那很正常
是不是 對啊
我又不是每天講漲停板 是不是
這個跟大家講
哲哲的投資誠信絕對不用懷疑
好不好 一定都有買
而且你們都可以作證
我要買聯發科的時候
我有說我考慮再買
這個跟大家講
上週一直暗示華邦電
也有暗示聯發科
沒有關係 好不好
這個跟大家講
哲哲每個禮拜剪頭髮
大概兩到三個禮拜剪一次
不好意思
這跟我對身材的標準一樣
重訓 每個禮拜一到兩週
跑步 每週都一定要來個三次以上
到這個年紀其實要維持蠻難的
這跟大家講
哲哲可以捐雲梯車嗎 突破你自己
最好那種巨型雲梯車是不是
聽說台灣的雲梯車
好像只有7樓 8樓而已是不是
好像沒有到21樓的
所以你房子不要買太高
這個跟大家講
AGI如果套用到機器人身上會怎麼樣
對啊 他就是人了啊
你看AGI現在最重要是
他沒有辦法動你知道嗎 你懂不懂
這個跟大家講 來
相信一波國巨
國巨我覺得可以買啦 為什麼
因為到時候都會缺貨
相信我 都會缺貨
電子股會熱很久
國巨最大問題是什麼 籌碼啦
散戶沒關係 籌碼你要開心嘛
你知道為什麼今年哲哲績效那麼好嗎
我不去亂追高 你看
3324雙鴻
你看為什麼今天又下去了
接下來股票只要拉上去
就有主力大戶 中實戶給你尻下來
2377微星 為什麼微星
微星創新高就有人給你殺下去
所以我就說我不想追高
今年績效為什麼不錯 不想追高
你懂不懂
所以6488環球晶
籌碼現在有點亂你就買 該買就買
等到噴出去 你為什麼要去買
奇怪我都不太懂
為什麼要去買1000多塊的欣興呢
900多塊也很貴啊
為什麼要去買這些
我不懂耶
你知道我剛才講什麼168
那時候誹謗我
那時候他們講的時候
欣興罵我的時候
我都不太懂耶
罵我說70幾塊
到底誰害誰
你看聽到那些人講我的話
網路亂傳的謠言
最後陸續還我清白了
我問你啊 現在變成快1000塊了
聽到的那些人馬上賣在最低點
可憐的是那時候不相信我的會員們
你相信我 10萬點
你真的不相信我
怎麼樣你就買個台灣50好不好
至少賺個1倍嘛 好不好
我不會說百分之百
但是我覺得機率很高
為什麼我捨身取義 取1億
捨身取億 不錯喔
這句話我把它記起來
捨身取億 告訴你台灣50 OK
我寫這個東西幹嘛
比我收一個會員還少耶
你懂不懂
賺幾萬塊
賺個2 30萬就偷笑了
第一名也是這樣子
所以賣書 很多人為什麼後來不出書
賺書錢很辛苦
真的賺書錢很辛苦
這個跟大家講
為什麼 這個是什麼
從頭到尾就是ETF買 你懂不懂
連台積電今年都賺50% 60%
所以放著買就好了
你們要放著是不是
OK嗎 要放著好不好
哲哲這一波回測多少
我不知道
可是我跟你講回測不多
為什麼 你們還是聽不懂我的話
去年的時候 26000的時候
我看到Gemini
狂贏ChatGPT
尤其做圖方面有沒有
去年11月的時候
我就喊36000到4萬
大家都不相信
東森還有報導 大家都不相信
東森主播報導這件事情
沒有人喔
沒有人跟你講36000 4萬
沒有啦 你不要看動輒
前陣子喊45000 5萬
他們都是漲到4萬多點才喊5萬
遜掉了 沒有人
所以我那時候是看到一個趨勢
然後還有AI agent的趨勢
所以他一路漲
漲到4萬 漲到45000
現在他有AGI
你們聽不懂我昨天講那麼多
AGI很恐怖
而且AGI會創造很多商業價值
他真的可以取代人力
Google也在裁員
他真的可以創造很多人力
你們不論是工程師也好
可是工程師我覺得你被裁這個地方
你能力架構強
你還是可以去別的地方上班
我最怕的是那些客服人員
一般行政人員
你們要注意一下
這個很快都會被取代
因為以後寫程式很快 你懂嗎
以後寫程式很快 好不好
那只是要不要花錢而已
有很多公司可能躍躍欲試
我是跟大家講
以前寫架構一定要拜託
因為所有公司都有行政流程
而且非常繁複的行政流程
以後都可以經過掃描拍照的方式
然後直接架構所有的行政流程
比如說我們會員等級
每個老師的不同的會員等級
然後要參加3個月 參加1年
有很多會員參加1年的
然後怎麼分配
每一個時期要開 怎麼開通
你懂不懂我的意思
什麼時間開通 日期記好
什麼時候時間結束
以前都要填資料 慢慢Key in
現在其實你只要設計好一個軟體
全部可以結束這一切
那以前設計是你要找設計公司
你要找程式設計公司來處理
他們不想要賺你們這種Case
他喊個300萬 你嫌太貴
可是你以後跑個程式
你可能只要5 60萬
就可以搞定這個事情
然後可以省幾百萬
甚至幾千萬的人事費用
每一家公司都有繁雜的行政程序
以後通通可以大幅減短那個流程
你們要記得我的預測
我最強的是預測
我最變態的是預告能力
你們記得一件事
我不喜歡當那種每天漲停板
沒什麼 那真的很Low
那對我來說
我根本就沒有那麼在乎錢
在乎錢我幹嘛捐那麼多救護車
是不是
你不能說我不愛錢 我還是愛錢
但是我沒有那麼
跟一般人比 我沒有那麼在乎
不然我美債幹嘛一直放著
我少賺1億
我是說真的 你都可以去做這些東西
人在做天在看
所以網路上如果誰說我造假
你幫我直接罵他
我該提告 我一定提告
我不在乎 我後來發現
這種人不能
你們要說我愛告人也沒關係
我覺得這種人都不能
以後看到一次 該告就告
律師費我告訴你 我不在乎
所以你們不要那些同業或網友亂造謠
你可以講我
至少最近績效還不差
績效不好的時候
你想罵我就算了
投資誠信 一件都不能講
因為我不會亂搞你
我不會騙你
我不可能跟主力配合
我不可能故意讓你賠錢
賺賠 有賺有賠
但我不會故意讓你賠
記得這件事情
我也不會故意突然變變變
突然變一個漲停板的股票
不會 我不可能有假簡訊這件事情
這個不用考慮
不可能的事情 好不好
你們其實找分析師也要找
先找不會騙你們的再說 好不好
其實我知道有些老投顧
我不要講誰 看就知道
就是還是有些虛擬的等級
真的有些人是這樣子
再不然就是我買一堆股票
其實我的股票沒有買很多
你參加我的會員就知道
沒有買很多
我沒有非常積極
每天一定要就是殺進殺出 你懂嗎
有些人為什麼每天漲停板
就一直買 然後一直換股票
我沒有 這個跟大家講好不好
哲哲精材好強
你看我今天可以講精材
問題是為什麼我現在沒講
我要收會員 我今天講10分鐘精材
我問你全台灣股票有誰比精材強
你看我到現在才講精材
我要先安撫你的國巨
國巨也沒什麼好安撫的
昨天的時候我所有會員還賺錢
當然我這一兩天有再加碼
誰的股票比我精材強
現在行情誰比精材強
精材我講了好久 你知不知道
我講了不是幾個月而已
也是被人家洗洗洗
前陣子也被人家罵
我要收會員
我講20分鐘精材就好了
不要跟你解釋那麼多
什麼真訊息 假訊息
我不可能做這種事 不需要
說老實話那對我收會員沒有幫助
我就感覺爽而已
我要告訴大家
你要看得懂我的未來
為什麼一堆新聞跟你講
你告訴我
現在所有新聞
你看工商時報
法人 台股年底登5萬點
廢話 現在不是要年底了
就是下半年 你是在
為什麼要看這個
你為什麼
他4萬點的時候
不敢PO這個新聞
法人也會有壓力
沒有人像我那麼有Guts
39000的時候
跌破4萬點最低點這邊
我告訴你買1億
投資朋友
你要的就是不一樣
我要6萬點賣掉
我要賺5千萬
我告訴大家捐一台救護車
我是跟大家講真的 好不好
6萬點賣掉 你說哲哲
那賣掉你不是看10萬點
不用擔心
我賣掉是賣
賣掉以後我還會再買回來
我只是要告訴你
我有獲利入袋了
我要捐救護車了 OK嗎
你看誰敢在這邊買
你告訴我誰敢在這邊買
那AGI這是頭版新聞 5萬點
你看我是不是講什麼
我那時候講得很清楚
43000可惜
那時候我還預告 是不是
47000可憐
現在喊5萬
都跟著我一起喊
5萬可悲
你沒有進場的可悲
我不是說喊5萬的人
你們5萬還沒有進場
或還有錢的人會可悲
你相信我 好不好
所以你們現在要開心
行情本來就不要一下子漲完
漲完不好玩
你們看到所有頭版新聞
你看新聞什麼裁員的東西
我不是都預告會很多人被裁員嗎
是不是
監控技術跟不上
我不是說90度角的成長幅度嗎
AI成長幅度嗎
監控技術當然跟不上
我昨天這個都跟你講過了
我上禮拜還特地講這個故事
為什麼現在才出這個新聞
你看到所有重要新聞
郭哲榮哪一件沒有先講到
哪一件 是不是
然後AGI時代來了
我不是說記憶體很重要
我都說記憶體缺了 那不可能
AGI很多人在講
這個新聞我再給你解釋一下
這個不用 這個新聞應該差不多
架構要升級 為什麼
因為你要找一個Partner
你不能找一個老人痴呆的Partner
記憶力不好 有能力有什麼用
是不是 這個跟大家講好不好
說到記憶力不好
我跟你講 我看很多人記憶力不好
譬如說馬總統 前任馬總統
我不是消費他
因為我覺得他有毅力可以跑三鐵
他那年紀5 60歲
70歲還可以跑三鐵
為什麼他比一般人
這麼好的身材比一般人
為什麼比較容易老人痴呆
我有查一下
感覺睡眠比較不足
所以你們睡眠要足 好不好
睡眠要足 記憶力才好
為什麼突然講這個東西 好不好
不要後面才吃
你後面才吃銀杏
你最大大問題是怎麼樣
你會忘記吃銀杏
所以也沒得救
這是開玩笑的
真的 記得這件事情好不好
記憶力很重要
記憶體也很重要
身體要養好 好不好
平常心 不要給自己那麼大壓力
相信哲哲 好不好
這個行情是老天爺送給大家的
也是老天爺送給哲哲的
我很開心這個行情
你不要去亂用融資貸款
因為他到10萬點
可能到10萬點的時候
他是有個泡沫存在
什麼叫泡沫存在
就是AI發展是真的
但是投資太快
那時候才有可能
所以我為什麼說
不會像2000年網路泡沫
我覺得他是像1996年 1997年
才剛開始AGI
有腦袋 夠聰明的人
在科技業的人
就知道AGI是多恐怖
因為你們一般人不知道
就是因為你們一般人不知道
所以行情總在半信半疑中成長
所以有人會賣股票
等到你們全面知道
AGI是這個
阿公 阿嬤
通用的AI
好厲害 像人類一樣這樣思考
好厲害 不懂的東西都會懂
不需要去搜尋資訊
他已經很厲害 他會去學習了
這麼厲害喔
跟以前這樣搜尋的AI不太一樣
那我跟你講
那時候才會網路泡沫
真的 你相信我
這些新聞不是都有講嗎
我都講了 好不好
都講了 這個跟大家講
所以這些新聞只是講在前面
我要是要告訴大家
你們真的很幸福
這是你們 這是那個
這是你們最悲劇的開始
也是喜劇的開始 你懂嗎
這是最不好的時代
也是最好的時代
雙城記 這是序言
這是最不好的時代
也是最好的時代
我也同樣送給大家
為什麼是最不好的時代
不用AI 不投資AI
你們真的要擁抱AI
不論是擁抱AI股
或者你要去買
要ChatGPT
Gemini都要訂閱
你相信我1000多塊
你越用它
你知道為什麼很多人
從馬斯克賺到錢嗎
他無論去買馬斯克的車子 買什麼
可是那只是你去賭
你去賭馬斯克
我們賭的是整個趨勢
馬斯克要是生病怎麼辦
我賭的是整個趨勢
趨勢不會改變
這個發展太恐怖了
我再講一次
AI的發展會超乎你想像
所以股市就算漲到10萬點
你們認識我20年了
就算有些人少說也有5 6年
什麼時候我敢跟你講
行情講這麼肯定
只差沒有講百分之百
我再強調一次
我不能講百分之百 我也不會講
因為所有事沒有百分之百
可是我基本上
我是很肯定語氣告訴你
10萬點他會很快
比你想像中快得來到
台積電你會看到變5000塊
所以我想很遠
所以為什麼希望主管機關
希望各個券商
你們真的要開發個軟體
或者是說再通過
台灣要零股制
不要用一張制
一個台積電現在是怎樣
2470元 一張247萬
如果以後變5000元呢
台灣股市不只會10萬點
可能15到20萬點
那換算成台積電有可能一張
你現在一張就247萬
以後一張1000萬誰要買
你說叫人家買零股
零股就是
你為什麼不把它湊在一起呢
你就是 來 2470元
一股就是多少
2470元
所以我有1萬塊
我也不會覺得台積電很貴
我只有1萬塊
就把它零股化
真的你相信我
我真的相信各個官員
我相信很多人看我的節目
我是為大家著想
遲早會改變的
相信我遲早會改變
那台灣現在制度是併軌制
以後交易時間變九點
我覺得OK 那還是麻煩
為什麼還是麻煩
譬如說我要買500萬
先買2張再湊個零股
20股 30股 幹嘛
就全部就多少股
就全部用一股為單位
不就搞定了嗎
一股為單位
一股就是2470元
不是247萬
那你要買一張
就是湊1000股就好
就變成247萬 就這麼簡單
為什麼我一直在講這個
因為我看到台灣股市10萬點的未來
我再講一次 10萬點的未來
甚至20萬點的未來
好不好 20萬點我不敢說
但是10萬點短期內很快就會到
請你記得我的話好不好
外資還在買
那我再跟大家講一件東西
你看 我今天可以跟你講精材
我也可以跟你講
我都不太懂
你們怎麼會覺得我會造假
我再講一次
我該提告一定告
哲哲就敢砸錢砸這些
我講真的
不要網路亂造謠好不好
哲哲這種錢最敢花
救護車我都敢花了
這個我一定敢花好不好
律師費我一定敢花
我也是跟大家講
所以化被動為主動
主動88專案
你看我現在才講
我也沒有勉強大家
自己參考
專案過了就過了
不要明天被動元件漲停
你又說我要參加這個專案 好不好
今天還有 好不好
明天應該也還有 好不好
為什麼我說這個東西很重要
我今天給你一個我獨家的東西跟你講
這是獨家
我本來想開一個專題
你們看一下
這是我在做的事情
這是什麼東西你知道嗎
從1964年來有沒有看到
薪資的報酬有沒有看到
這張圖很重要
薪資的報酬是這樣走
再看一次
導播你們都要學會
我是送給你們
薪資的報酬是這樣走有沒有看到
沒錯吧
這是橘色薪資報酬有沒有看到
薪資報酬這樣走
這是什麼 S&P 500
S&P 500這幾年的報酬
遠輸於那斯達克跟費半報酬
我用最遜的S&P 500
好不好 OK嗎
有沒有看到 薪資報酬漲多少
漲多少 漲10倍
從1964年來薪水漲10倍
有沒有跟上那個S&P的報酬
S&P才幾倍 100倍
從1964年代薪資
所以為什麼人家說薪資趕不上通膨
那你要怎麼做 你知道嗎 來
畫面給我
這張圖你們一定要記得一輩子
尤其你們是還在當人家打工仔的
其實我跟你講
現在當老闆也沒有比較好
他說現在 我聽很多朋友
現在台灣人
台灣很難找那個員工 對啊
來 我們看
薪資是10倍對不對
薪資從1964年是漲10倍對不對
1000% 10倍對不對
S&P 500報酬是100倍
所以什麼意思
所以你為什麼
認知啊
為什麼很多人考上台大
很多人是當醫生
但是他賺的錢
他們就可以自命清高
我不想要投資股票
可是不會啊 連趙建銘都投資股票了
只是感覺不知道投資好或不好
我不知道
不要殺進殺出
叫他多看哲哲的節目
他就不會跟他太太前妻吵架了
薪水為什麼10倍
因為很多醫生是完全不投資的
以前可以 現在不行
現在醫生的薪水沒像以前那麼高
你工程師也不行
為什麼薪資10倍 投資是100倍
代表是你更要投資
你為什麼覺得薪水趕不上通膨幅度
事實上沒有錯
只有投資才可以抗通膨
而且投資是S&P 500
S&P 500像台灣50這樣子
的ETF這樣子 好
那又有人說第一桶金很重要
我再教你
所以年輕人
你們要先把第一桶金
存起來以後怎麼樣
你本來是這一條線
你什麼都不動就這條線對不對
看你什麼時候怎麼樣
趕快把薪資這條路的錢
轉換成這樣 記起來
轉換成 你本來是這一條台鐵的道路
你要轉換成高鐵的道路
你才跟得上幅度
懂嗎 我再講一次
你們不要怨天尤人
那是因為你們
沒有分析師跟你們講這些東西
他們只會每天講漲停板
他們真的有些人根本不是替你想
他只想要你
怎麼樣從你身上挖最多錢
我不是 我真的希望你們共享
認識我的都知道
我的朋友 我也不報明牌
你就買台灣50
我給你報明牌
我報個比如說
我2 300塊的時候我看好國巨
你可能自己買1000多 你怪我
不需要
長期你謝謝我就好 好不好
我今天有點反光是不是
太白是不是
有嗎 導播有嗎
還好 注意一下
再給你講結論 你聽清楚
這是台鐵的道路
你要高鐵道路怎麼辦 你要轉過去
所以趕快存好第一桶金 趕快轉過去
有錢就趕快轉過去 懂嗎
這樣子股市成長的速度你才會跟上去
那現在會是最高潮的時候
因為以前沒有AI
你要相信我的判斷
COVID-19的時候
只有我說一年內會產生疫苗
我是預言家
我喜歡當預言家
以後你們就知道郭哲榮10萬點
你知道為什麼
沒有一個電視台在捧我
我算電視台出身的
其實我不喜歡那個制度
因為你買電視節目以前很貴
我很不喜歡
就變成說老師一定要常常講漲停板
這也不能怪電視台
就是一個畸形的制度 你知道嗎
買個節目要100萬以上
半小時100萬你知道嗎
所以很多分析師以前
為什麼舊投顧
有些人習慣他還是要講漲停板
沒有 他不講漲停板沒辦法
搞得像詐騙集團 這沒辦法
可是我不喜歡
舊媒體時代你看有誰捧過我
為什麼現在我那麼多粉絲
因為很多粉絲是看我的節目
看我5年 看10年
郭哲榮你講得真的對
所以我要告訴你是
從一個數字告訴你
薪資經過個50年 60年只有漲10倍
股市可以讓你100倍
他是最好抗通膨的工具
所以你每天辛辛苦苦的幫人家賺錢
你不投資
你每天就傻傻在這條道路上
你永遠只能坐台鐵
人家坐高鐵
然後你怪天怪地 怨天尤人有什麼用
你不去思考
這一段很重要
你們記得這一段很重要
我希望你們記清楚好不好
有時候這種其實我應該要貼影片
但是我不要貼
我要送給那些願意看我長片的人
就是你
60秒的人一定少賺很多
這一段很重要好不好
電視台 不是電視台不好
那是以前比較畸形的制度
現在網路化了
所以電視台跟不是電視台不重要
重點是媒體內容好不好
這個跟大家講
剛才這一段OK嗎
你都坐高鐵的 時間就是金錢
20年前高鐵隨便坐
現在很像台鐵化了
這一段大家好像不太喜歡
所以你們一定要把薪水的錢
把定存的錢 活存的錢
那我這一段還有一個東西
這是薪資
我認為定存應該也差不多這個比例
你們定存這種報酬
你們自己不換個飛機坐
不從台鐵換成飛機坐 是不是
那也傻了好不好
看這個數字就知道
不投資是傻瓜 知不知道
那為什麼投資有人會賠錢
太急了 你每天追高殺低幹什麼
你看我的節目不覺得看一看
你本來很多人在4萬點賣股票
有什麼好賣的 分散投資
這檔股票地雷股
對 我也有踩過地雷股
分散就好了
對 網路上還有人說是我的助理
那個亂講的
雖然我很認真
我不喝咖啡的好不好
Threads寫得很厲害
哲哲很認真 毛利率提高
是啦 我是很認真
但是那不是我的助理
認識我的就知道我不喝咖啡
這個跟大家講 來
台勝科8月營收剛公布13.32億
你們拜託 你們用公布營收
不要給我一個沒有前沒有尾的
你們是當我是1800檔
我都記得上個月營收多少
要跟我講7月營收
沒關係 請助理幫我查一下7月營收
月增 年增一定要告訴我好不好
哲哲真的是有良心的分析師
各位打工仔真的要聽進去
你們真的 你們每天怨天尤人
我跑Uber 我好辛苦
不是啊 你要投資啊
我當然知道享受人生也很重要
可是你同時並進 你要投資
你要記得我剛才講的
你為什麼不把台鐵的路換成高鐵路
把台鐵的路換成坐飛機的速度
你一定要記得我剛才那一段
你們就想清楚 對
不然你們就像在
那種什麼老鼠
鐵籠裡面的老鼠 忘記了
就一直跑 一直跑 一直跑
那叫什麼 導播你知道叫什麼嗎
不知道沒關係 好不好
籠子裡面的老鼠一直跑 一直跑
跑那個迴圈 好不好
真的是這樣子好不好
這個跟大家講
哲哲有見聞色霸氣
相信我看的未來
我看趨勢很厲害
我如果趨勢不厲害
我會是全台灣數一數二
那個成立LINE的嗎
我是台灣第一個成立TG的
我是全台灣 是不是
分析師訂閱人數最多的
就是因為我都做第一個 你懂嗎
我又沒有人捧我
就是我都做第一個
我都知道趨勢在哪邊
為什麼我稍微經營Threads
我馬上人數就變那麼多
就幾十萬了
因為我知道趨勢在哪邊
你要懂我在說這個東西
我可以講20分鐘我的股票很強
我是要告訴你真的要10萬點
忍一下就好
天竺鼠 哈姆太郎
時間不早了 該談股票了
我剛才從頭到尾都在談股票
只是你們談的股票是單一股票
你剛才不知道我談的是股票
那太遜了
那你也不適合我
我要告訴你 我推薦的股票基本上
很多還會再漲一倍以上
一倍算少
記得我這件事
聯發科我那時候也講一陣子 好不好
聯發科我跟你講還會再進場 好不好
聯發科這個再說一次
不需要質疑我的投資誠信
我不屑
還有人說
哲哲 這真的假的
我再講一次
再讓我看到
我該查我會查
不論花多少錢 我不在乎
不要以為網路時代都一定找不到各位
是要找不找而已
這該提告我都提告
這個聯發科下去
你該買就買
而且我覺得最好笑的是你看
看我節目有時候40分鐘
光在講未來趨勢就講20分鐘
我有很認真在講股票嗎
有些人覺得沒有
所以我有必要去造假這些東西嗎
不多說了 來
我簡訊有刻意造假 我給大家1億
有刻意造假 故意做壞事的話
環球晶要噴了嗎
選股達人哲哲
定存銀行也是買投信基金
對啊 銀行定存
他也是去買基金沒錯
他很多去買基金啊
41分了 好 不好意思
我們講股票
我們先講那個
先講 精材剛剛講過沒
精材還沒講嗎 精材講過沒
148%講過是不是 賺那麼多
我喝個水
講聯發科好了
聯發科你幫我念一下好不好
來 昨天的簡訊
好 9月7號禮拜一 昨天的簡訊
恭喜2454聯發科
我們上週五進場
今天馬上噴漲停
現買現賺真開心
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
很多人覺得我沒講股票
其實我講的都是股票
你看 4萬點到現在
我們在討論5萬點
其實我們是7月31號的事情
到現在不到一個半月
他其實過很快
所以10萬點會很快
你們是 你們太急的是
你們把一天當一年用
不要急好不好
聯發科有機會再噴出去好不好
然後我講記憶體 因為AGI的關係
因為他AGI已經可以思考了
他可以做很多事情
他可以訓練很多事情
他可以通用 他就像一個人類一樣
你可以叫他做事情還不用思考
以前他只是像頂多一個電腦助理
他現在像人類一樣 不同了
會學東西 好不好
而且很多東西可以學得很好
那很恐怖
而且他只是初階一代
他還可以再進步 還可以再進步
我跟你說真的 我還是要強調
這10萬點真的很容易達到
你相信我看到的未來好不好
我真的 你們以後會覺得我很恐怖 很變態
這個我說真的 我最喜歡預測未來
相信我看到的未來好不好
不然我怎麼敢在39000的時候買
連續三年
都買在相對最低點這附近
台勝科我們看一下營收
我們請助理看一下營收 來
不錯啊 你看台勝科就很純啊
這種營收 你跟我講什麼
就微微在增啊 矽晶圓有沒有看到
這很漂亮啊
年增 雖然月增有點少啊
但是就是很漂亮的月增啊
年增率很高啊 年增率比之前高啊
所以代表去年8月是淡季 你看
月增只有2% 但是年增29%
代表年增越來越高啊 有沒有
這13億 有沒有看到
從11.9 11.7
4月還下滑 這個5 6 7 8
都在增加
台勝科我還想買
助理提醒我一下啦 台勝科
真的買得不夠多 好不好
提醒我一下 助理
不代表我明天一定買
我只是叫助理提醒我
所以明天環球晶
跟台勝科有機會拉起來
但是我不能說這營收非常漂亮 不差
不差 因為台勝科已經漲上去了
但是矽晶圓缺貨是真的 還會更缺
先跟你講
我認為營收明年再增長個50%
甚至100%不是不可能
我先預告在前面
因為會比你想像中的缺貨
你會覺得我很恐怖啦 好不好
3374精材
我不是跟你講說 我說大戶在洗
我有說這次洗成功會很恐怖
我有沒有講 有啦
所以精材在洗好不好
有精材的人不要走 不要走
先等600元再說 我是認真的
對 沒有錯 先漲一倍再說
先等600元再說 好不好
華邦電也不要走 它正式要突破了
今天創收盤價新高
算很厲害 好不好
華邦電真的很厲害 好不好
NAND 還有記憶體相關都還會缺貨
聯發科你喜歡買高價格
聯發科我認為買就對了 好不好
買就對了 好不好
當然分散投資 好不好
還有什麼股票
南亞科其實在拉嘛
南亞科我現在沒有
微星 微星就是這樣
微星寧願 但是它不是非常純AI
寧願拉回買 不要追高買好不好
2376技嘉也是一樣
寧願拉回買
所以拉回你要開心
如果真的要買的話
5347世界先進
哲哲怎麼下去了
不用擔心 到時候該拉起來就拉起來
好不好 今天很多股票是跟大家講
我們來看一下
摺疊手機明天再講
對 我們這禮拜最重要的是CPI
CPI不要太高
對不起 我講太多總經
所以我現在總經再講快一點
我剛才不是講總經
我剛才講的是很多投資的故事
CPI我們看一下
CPI對不對
預期對不對
現在預期3.4%有沒有看到
助理 預期3.4%
持平就很厲害了
持平就有機會不升息了 好不好
因為畢竟川普
任命的Fed主席還是有差 OK嗎
所以只要預期3.4%
禮拜五晚上
這禮拜最重要是禮拜五晚上8點半
如果沒有要升息
9月開Party了 好不好
那如果要升息會比較動亂
我就不知道怎麼說
可是如果CPI低於3.4%
如果你期貨想要做當沖
你那天就沖就對了
3.3%先沖再說
漲200點 我覺得還會漲更多
我先給你預告
所以這一個月最重要就是CPI數據
因為他是要看通膨數據
通膨數據比就業數據更重要
決定要不要升息 降息
也是通膨數據
記得我真的是預言家
我2022年就是從12000
這樣一路做上來的
我那時候還說一個月內漲1000點
那時候一個月內漲1000點
等同於現在一個月內漲4000點
我敢跟大家賭雞排
我不是跟你賭
我就說沒有我就送雞排給大家
結果答對了好不好
這個跟大家講 OK嗎
不要洗板 什麼洗板
又有人在洗板
對 不要一直洗板
想聽智原
智原我覺得就是比較擦邊球
智原我有點想換
不是他不好 他基期很低
他就是擦邊球
AI的擦邊球
你要比較純的
像以前聯發科也是AI的擦邊球
現在就變成AI的核心了
營收開始灌起來了
那我是覺得你可以換
如果智原你覺得慢的話
你可以來找我 好不好
或許你可以想
我想要不要給你換好不好
當然不代表他不好 好不好
你不要只重壓一檔股票
記得我這些東西好不好
那個摺疊手機
好像是什麼時候
後天 明後天再跟你講
那時候我會買第一批的摺疊手機
我會買兩台
一個摺疊手機 一個正常的
我都試看看好不好
跟你們講哪個好用
我做研究好不好
現在股票不要追
今天我1億的0050一度賺1900萬
快2000萬了 好不好
是不是很快
我還要等一段時間好不好
再等一段時間
等6萬點 明年很快就6萬點
記得我說的話
明年很快就6萬點
很快 很快
到時候說
哲哲你那時候39000的時候
我應該用力買
現在幾分了 48
還有沒有股票 沒有了
華邦電很強 真的要噴出去了
今天最強是精材 好不好
所以我要講的是 來
主動88專案
被動元件還是很強
被動元件你要謝謝他
怎麼漲一天跌一天
很謝謝他
因為被動元件也會缺
你真的要謝謝他好不好
2492華邦電
不是華邦電 華新科
你要謝謝他
怎麼今天這樣子不行啦
他還是紅K
代表是開低走高
國巨實在籌碼太亂了
你不用擔心
圍魏救趙 好不好
鄉村包圍城市
到時候他們一起救國巨
籌碼亂 漲上去的時候你突然覺得
跌下去突然覺得
有人覺得老闆的信用好不好
你跌下去的時候才想到
我們跟你講 我們500元的時候
你就用力買 該買就買 好不好
我叫你ALL IN不是叫你說
只重壓一檔股票
你不是我的會員
你自己要拿捏
不要什麼都怪我
可是我覺得被動元件很OK
我很有信心 你看
全台灣有什麼股票比我的精材還強
你告訴我
我賺了100多%我還沒走
我賺了100多%還沒走
148%還沒走 很變態
我打算賺個500%
不是500% 這誇張了
我可能至少要賺個200%
甚至300% 不誇張
精材我是打算賺那麼多
我才走 好不好
200%啦
基本上沒有200%我不會想走
我那時候環球晶就賺了快200%了
我也沒走
所以全台灣有誰的股票比我們還強
現在幾分了
49要結束了
精材你看最後還可以拉起來
你看這個處置制度
改變後差很多
大戶敢拉就敢拉
2分鐘處置一次也沒關係 他不怕
到底全台灣有誰比我的精材還強
你看現在 最近記憶體最強的
是華邦電 也是很強
我們也有恭賀簡訊
精材賺148%
華邦電呢 今天也大漲
手上持股獲利續抱
聯發科呢
目前為止應該也是賺錢中
就是應該賺錢
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
好不好 最後跟大家講
趕快來
我覺得台灣股市很開心是
快5萬點了
很多股票
現在跌到3萬點左右 4萬點左右
不就是被動元件
所以化被動為主動
主動88專案
哲哲主動通知你
希望你主動88 主動發發發
主動88專案
不論是被動元件也好 記憶體也好
台積電資本支出 精材也好
我們好多飆股
矽晶圓 環球晶這些等著要噴出了
今天台勝科營收也不錯
這些股票會不會噴出呢
拭目以待
化被動為主動
主動88專案
隨時截止
歡迎趕快 大家趕快來參加
這個專案好不好
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye